[Music]
what does it mean to be playing at the
2019 US Women's Championship you know
it's a great honor to be invited and
it's a pleasure to be competing against
so many strong players in the United
States I mean I haven't played for a few
years so I'm pretty excited to be back
um yeah pretty excited to play my best
chess yet
hopefully I think it's always special
for me to play neros championship every
year is a chance to try to win it I
guess it's really nice because I was
here two years ago but I didn't do so
well so I guess I just want to come back
and redeem myself I'm really looking
forward to this year's event I mean I
haven't won in a in a few years almost
been three years so hopefully I can do
better this time I think it's very
important event for me and this is
definitely the most important chess
event of the year and I'm very excited
to play I don't know how many US
Championship already played yeah it
means a lot because I lost time I came
was like three years ago so it's good to
be back and also now that I'm in college
it also helps to publicize it's a good
thing for the school too so yeah I'm
really excited to be back I hope I do
well obviously it's actually my fifth
year playing so so I have like a lot of
experience now so I'm really excited for
this year these tournaments are like
very fun to play in and I'm happy to
just be back here and playing this
tournament again feels really good I'm
happy I got selected and I hope to do my
best and just play it's great to be back
in San Luis it's always a pleasure being
here I think this is my eleventh time or
12th time can you can keep count of it
but um I'm sure it's gonna be a really
exciting event